There's a lot about the Crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover spectacular that ultimately
made it a rip-roaring success, but there were
plenty of awkward and inexplicable moments
as well.
Let's take a look at the five best and worst
moments in Crisis On Infinite Earths.
Turning Oliver Queen into the Spectre, the
universe's agent of justice and vengeance,
was a stroke of genius that many viewers never
saw coming.
Episode four of Crisis On Infinite Earths
had a conclusion similar to the comic.
Oliver channeled the energy of his friends,
the Paragons, in order to defeat the Anti-Monitor
and restart the Big Bang.
All of that was less interesting than the
smaller, character-driven moments that Spectre-Oliver
spent with his friends in that episode, as
he guided them through his memories in order
for them to survive various plot contrivances.
The heart of the Arrowverse has always been
Oliver Queen and Barry Allen's unlikely friendship,
as Oliver drew inspiration from Barry's love
and Barry drew strength from Oliver's resolve.
The show gave them the closure they needed
and deserved.
In the course of the Arrowverse, when crossovers
get bigger, the story starts to make less
sense.
In episode one of Crisis, the Monitor tells
the heroes that the last stand will be on
Supergirl's Earth-38.
In subsequent episodes, that gets changed
to Earth-1, as he suddenly tells everyone
to find the Paragons who would help defeat
the Anti-Monitor, who then shows up to destroy
everything, at which point it becomes all
about defeating the Anti-Monitor at the beginning
of time.
There's a long digression during which they
try to prevent the Monitor from ever traveling
through time; finally, the Anti-Monitor's
first defeat doesn't quite stick, so they
need to find a new way to deal with him by
sending him to the Microverse.
"Essentially we'd be sending him to the 'Atomverse.'"
"I like to call it the Microverse."
"Oh that's better.
Possible trademark issues, but that's better."
It all adds up to a crossover's worth of MacGuffins,
as it was rarely clear as to what was going
on and why other than a vague sense of the
universe coming to an end.
With a meandering plot and a villain who barely
appeared on the screen, Crisis On Infinite
Earths was saved by the scenery-chewing greatness
of Jon Cryer as Lex Luthor.
It's not just that his Luthor is a smarmy
know-it-all with a vicious streak that's a
delight to watch.
"Never thought I'd say this, but I'm tired
of killing Supermen."
This Luthor is also a plot-generating machine.
Almost every second he's onscreen, he's coming
up with schemes to take advantage of the Crisis
and punish his enemies Superman and Supergirl.
When the multiverse was in danger, Lex steals
the book of destiny in order to kill Superman
in every reality, leading to some of the best
cameos in the crossover, like Lex confronting
the grown-up Clark Kent from Smallville only
to find out that he had given up his powers.
When going back in time to prevent the Monitor
from accidentally releasing the Anti-Monitor,
Lex tries to manipulate the Monitor instead,
and when the multiverse is rewritten, Lex
changes things so he's now a hero.
No matter what he did throughout Crisis, Lex
had clear motives, a smart plan, and ruthless
ambition.
The Arrowverse shows have always been known
for excellent action set pieces.
What did we get in Crisis On Infinite Earths?
A bunch of shadow minions that disappeared
on contact.
Even non-powered, non-combatant Dr. Ryan Choi
was able to beat them up with just his two
fists.
The final confrontations with the Anti-Monitor
felt anti-climactic, as those battles wrapped
up quickly and with a minimum of spectacular
things to look at on screen.
It's enough to make you wish the Anti-Monitor
had summoned various supervillains to be his
minions, even if only for a scene or two.
One of the pleasures of the crossover is seeing
Kate Kane emerge as a significant hero in
her own right.
In a crossover with a few clever swerves,
the best comes after traveling to Gotham City
on Earth-99 in episode two in order to find
one of the Paragons needed to defeat the Anti-Monitor.
In this case, it's Kevin Conroy, voice of
Batman from the '90s animated series, playing
Batman as an elderly, physically broken and
bitter man.
Supergirl and Batwoman are looking for the
Paragon of Courage, and for a while, it felt
like their role would be helping Batman regain
his courage, but this Batman is an even darker
version of the character from The Dark Knight
Returns, a stone-cold killer who'd even slain
Superman.
"Life only makes sense if you force it to!"
The real Paragon of Courage turns out to be
Kate Kane herself, who confronts her own demons
by defeating this twisted version of her cousin
in one of the best scenes of the crossover.
Tom Cavanagh is usually fun to watch as whatever
version of Harrison Wells appears on The Flash.
His most recent multiverse incarnation, Nash
Wells, seemed to be no exception while he
was tracking down the Monitor for his own
reasons.
Unfortunately, his motivations became increasingly
incoherent as he seemed to serve just as the
catalyst who freed the Anti-Monitor.
That was bad enough, but his later transformation
into a cosmic being known as the Pariah was
even more confusing.
His purpose and powers were maddeningly vague,
and he seemed to be little more than an instrument
to move the plot along.
Even when the world was reset and his memories
of his role in all of this were triggered,
his character didn't do much more than act
as a reminder that they hadn't won just yet.
Introducing the noble, stubborn Jefferson
Pierce, a.k.a. Black Lightning, into the Crisis
On Infinite Earths narrative as more than
just a cameo was another smartly-played plot
swerve.
Merging his universe with that of the Flash
and Supergirl means that all of the Arrowverse
shows are now operating in the same reality,
opening up the possibility of interesting
guest-star appearances and crossovers in the
future.
His reactions to the other heroes in the course
of the crossover were a highlight.
From his easy chemistry with Barry Allen,
to being taken aback by seeing two Supermen,
who were comic book characters in his reality,
to his wondering aloud about the necessity
of a base, he was a delight, and in the end,
he took his rightful place as part of the
Justice League.
The Anti-Monitor showed no agency or motivations
for his actions other than antimatter and
matter being unable to coexist in the same
place.
What little dialogue he had was mostly the
usual sort of blustery threats from your average
megalomaniacal super-villain.
For someone touted as an evil force surpassing
anything the heroes had ever encountered,
his main evil seemed to be sheer boredom.
His shadow minions were about as effective
and terrifying as paper ghosts.
Worst of all, he just seemed kind of dumb.
He seemed so certain of his victory that he
didn't seem to have any real plans or schemes
that the heroes had to deal with, nor did
he care to stop the heroes from doing what
they were doing.
The final scenes of episode five were note-perfect.
Beginning with Barry Allen and Sara Lance
eulogizing their friend Oliver Queen and setting
up an eternal flame for him to the old Super
Friends theme playing over the final reveal
of the Hall of Justice, the show leaned heavily
on DC Universe mythology and nostalgia.
With Oliver gone, it's only right that Barry
should be the new catalyst for the heroes,
and it's fitting that for the hero designated
as the Paragon of Love, his idea was a big
clubhouse where his friends could hang out.
The sheer look of glee on the actors' faces
when they sat at the round table of this new
Justice League was palpable, and it opens
up a multitude of storytelling possibilities.
The only character who died in the crossover
was Oliver Queen, and it took him a couple
of tries before he finally perished.
The Arrowverse has never been shy about killing
characters, so it may seem odd that in an
event as big as this there would be so few
permanent casualties, although it's easy to
understand this decision from a storytelling
perspective; the writers clearly wanted to
keep as many characters around as possible
for the revised realities of their TV shows.
Thematically, it was also clear that they
wanted to honor the Green Arrow and actor
Stephen Amell, as Arrow is ending.
Having too many characters sacrificing themselves
would have taken away from the focus on Oliver.
That said, it did feel like a cheat that pretty
much every significant character wound up
just fine in the end, even if their realities
were shuffled with a bit.
The heroes were supposed to be confronting
the end of everything, and the outcome didn't
reflect this.
Hopefully, future crossovers will be scaled
back a bit.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.